i want to just to tell some of these
stories just to air them out because i
know you people have heard me tell
stories on different podcasts and [__]
and like i always say i don't feel good
about all this [__] i did
but it brought me here to you guys
you know like sometimes i swear to god
there's some nights i [__] wake up
like you know i did coke for 30 years so
all that blow was doing was hiding those
those thoughts and those stories like i
this times now i'm just driving
and i'll see like a cat and i go oh my
god
what about the time i robbed that house
and we got attacked by a cat
we used to buy coke from this colombian
lady oh 17.
and we'd go over the house and give her
money and go can we get a gram and she'd
go yeah
i got to go in the room and she'd go in
the room and lock the door
then she'd come out and give you the
blow again one day we go and she's being
a [__] to us
no i can't fight you on a ball we're
robbing you
not tonight but soon so one friday we
wake up
by this time i was carrying a gun i used
to carry a gun and i had to stop that
because it's really
a gun is like a magnet for other guns
people only pulled guns on me when i was
carrying a gun
people only pull a knife on you when you
carry a knife because they're a magnet
i haven't had a gun on me in 20 years i
haven't seen a [__] gun on the street
but when i had a gun on me i everybody
had a [__] gun it seemed like
like it was like a clint eastwood movie
everybody had a [__] gun
what was i talking about the gun
the cat so i go over there with this kid
mike was my brother and this kid stinky
stinky was the lookout driver so in
those days
this was like a two-story balcony so i
couldn't climb so it's between stinky
and mike so they would do the 21st
finger is it
your mother told me you ever play that
one two three the 21st finger has to
climb all right
so i go mike climb the [__] thing and
go up there
and go in the room that's what she has
to blow mike's like
got it he climbs up the sewage pipe
he puts his leg over the balcony he
comes in there here
he goes i'm getting close you open up
the door nothing here
and he's like ah
and we're like what the [__] going on
at me and stinky in the bottom what the
[__]
mike shows up
he shows up you know those skinny ugly
skinny ugly siamese cats they're real
[__] they're on
the real ugly he had one on his head
right
like a hat and the claws were right here
and i could see like the white in his
[__] eyes like he's like
help me help me help me right
and went down like we'll help you just
throw the coke down
he's like there ain't no coke and this
guy
and he's like i'm coming down and i take
the gun out i'm like don't cut i'll
[__] shoot you
go back there you're in there already go
in there
it's a [__] cat kill the [__]
right
and you can see him i'll never forget
he's got the cat and he's pulling him
right
he's pulling him and the cat's claws are
in here like this
and finally he pull and you can see like
you hear like
like and i'm on the bottom floor like i
hear like
todd i'm like oh no he's like ah ah
he runs and he runs back he throws out
like a bag of blow
and he's like i'm coming we're like no
you're not she's got jewelry go back
there take every [__] thing
[Applause]
he runs back then he comes back i never
forget he it's like a [__]
comedy he's trying to get the cat off
but he's spinning
he's [__] scared and we're up there
like hurry up
he [__] finally i mean i'll never
forget like each thing
he gets it off he throws the cat and he
[__] doesn't even climb back down the
pole he just jumped
like he just said
we get in the car and i'm looking he's
like i'm getting more than everybody
look what this cat did to me right
you could see the claws like that staid
in his head
he looked like jesus remember when they
put the [__] thing
like he had blood going down his face
he white till this day i go you still
got claws in it he's like go [__]
himself
come on let me touch the clothes go [__]
yourself guy that was
and to me that doesn't even sound like a
bad story like we robbed the house how
bad is that you invaded somebody's
privacy
to us it was like they had a cat